but since your show is called never have
i ever i think with it we need to play a
quick round of never ever
you've never played i've never done this
yet for a brand new first time ever in
your life
we're gonna play never have i
[Applause]
all right ever grab your paddle here we
go i'm going to hit this button that's
super close i'm in proximity to me
and we both have to honestly say if we
have
or we have never done whatever comes up
are you ready
as i love her all right here we go boom
boom boom
oh this is this is wow gone skinny
dipping
oh cause i can't swim so why would i
want to be naked and drown
i can't swim i know i know like i need
to work on that
i need to work on that i know i'm wrong
this is like a survival thing but it's
like a lot of body movements you said
why would i ever want to be naked
and i don't wanna i don't wanna be naked
[Laughter]
[Music]
i will tell you i was terrified though
because i was also a nerd and i loved
like all the history channel things or
nat geo all that kind of stuff when i
was a kid
and i learned about the scene now
granted i think it was in the amazon but
this little thing that can crawl into
like your lady bits and and
and it can do some damage and so i was
kind of afraid to be naked in water even
though i wasn't in the amazon
i was like it's going to get you
traveling so i kind of swam like a
mermaid
it's like nothing's getting in there
i was protecting my goods that's what i
was doing all right here we go
spin the wheel
okay
if you're saying you have it that's such
a liar why do you think i own a dog
like that's that's my dog i've totally
blamed my dog melody
why'd you fart bro granted that was when
i was younger like now i'll just be like
my bad
like that's called accountability and
that's accountability and age
i think as age you just don't care yeah
nothing
it just it leaves um but i have blamed
my dog before
okay here's another one
there we go never have i ever sang to my
stuffed animals
yeah i have you have have you not i
you know what is that not a universal
experience
no specifically stuffed animals
no really but to like dolls like i don't
know if i did stuff
care bears yes i did i love care bears i
love carrot i love sunshine
i would line up my stuffed animals like
along my bed probably wasn't the best
because it didn't leave me enough room
to sleep but it was okay
you know you got to be kind my daughter
does that okay i line them up and then
being like my what like
eight-year-old nine-year-old self who
obviously knows about heartbreak i would
sing
them adele the most disappointing and
defeating part of this story is that you
were saying when i was a child listening
to adele
because well i understand i was not girl
here we go
never have i ever broken a bone oh
i have never i've never either i have
bent a bone
two what did you do i have fallen off a
horse and
bent my tailbone perpendicular to my
spine which i guess is a forever thing
super fun um and also i bent my pinkies
see
i was in a bike accident and i and i
yeah it's bent
battles never broken never broken that's
a song
bent but never broken let's write it
yeah i like that
it has a sauce on it i don't know i like
it i never broke anything
i fall down all the time but as a child
i would you know slip through like table
legs and like small gaps so i like
dislocated some stuff
but i think i was doing a favor to my
mom you know keeping her on her toes
yeah keeping things interesting like how
boring would it be if i didn't do that
stuff you're a half glass full kind of
girl
yeah i'm so glad you're sticking around
i love you
never have i ever is now on netflix and
season two is coming this july so
everybody look for it check it out
yup i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe if you don't i'll be
trapped in this box forever